vamos a dar un pequeño repaso acerca de
los números racionales los números
los racionales ración
es ahora los números racionales son
todos aquellos números que se pueden
representar como una fracción o visto
desde otra manera que se pueden
representar como una razón racionales
racionales suena narración y reacción
suena a razón se pueden ver como una
razón razón o una proporción una
proporción
ok por ejemplo todo número entero es un
número racional podemos pensar en el 1 y
es que el 1 lo podemos ver como 1 sobre
1 aquí lo estamos viendo como una
fracción o como una razón pero esto
también lo podemos ver como menos 2
entre menos 2 aquí está escrito de una
manera distinta pero como otra razón o
proporción o inclusive también lo
podemos ver como 10.000 10.000 entre
10.000 mismo ok y así puedo ponerte
miles de ejemplos de hecho una cantidad
infinita de formas de representar este 1
como una razón o una proporción
cualquier número entre cualquier número
entre ese mismo número es igual a 1
ahora también podemos pensar por ejemplo
en el -7 el menos siete es un número
entero y este número lo podemos ver como
menos 7 entre 1 o que aquí está
expresado como una razón con una
fracción y también lo podemos ver no ser
como 77
3 - 1 es otra forma de representar a
este menos 7 esto sirve también lo
podemos ver como a menos 14 menos 14
entre 2 se multiplicó tanto arriba como
abajo por 2 y así puedo ponerte también
varios ejemplos de cómo expresar a este
número menos 7 y bueno es un número
racional porque lo podemos ver como una
fracción ahora qué te parece si nosotros
pensamos en el número 3.75 el número
3.75 será un número racional y bueno la
respuesta es que el número 3.75 lo
podemos ver como 375 entre 100 estás de
acuerdo o lo que es lo mismo am se
multiplicó por dos la parte de arriba me
va a quedar 750 750 entre 200
multiplicando ambas partes por 2 o no sé
3.75 es lo mismo que tres enteros que
tres enteros tres cuartos
de los tres cuartos y bueno esto lo
podemos ver como una fracción impropia
si yo multiplico 3 por 4 12 3 son 15
cuartos 15 4 15 cuartos es decir que 3
puntos 75 también es lo mismo que 15
cuartos o poder multiplicar todo no sé
por menos 2 y esto es lo mismo que menos
30 entre menos 8 ok son varias formas de
representar como una razón como una
proporción como una fracción el número
3.75 bueno y qué pasa con los decimales
que se repiten a no ser se me ocurre
tomarme al decimal a 0.3 333 puntos
suspensivos sigue y sigue y sigue y
sigue que por cierto este es el decimal
que se repite que tal vez más conocido
sea y entonces esto es exactamente lo
mismo y no podemos visualizar como 0.3
periódicos y bueno hemos visto que esta
expresión aquí la podemos ver como
tercio que por cierto esta es una
fracción o es una razón entre dos
números enteros entre el 1 y el 3 y si
puedo tal vez pensar en antes que mi
primer de color am se me ocurre a 0.6
periódicos que también hemos visto que
es lo mismo que dos tercios y así puedo
tomar varios de estos decimales que se
repiten y de hecho todos los decimales
que se repiten siempre las podemos ver
como números racionales siempre hay
forma de escribirlos como la razón de
dos enteros sea cual sea si nosotros
tenemos no se me ocurre un número
decimal que después de un cierto tiempo
se empieza a repetir entonces lo podemos
escribir como una fracción y se puede
repetir no se después de dos decimales
tres decimales o un millón de decimales
no importa la cantidad de decimales que
sean mientras encontremos que se empiece
a repetir exactamente el mismo patrón
entonces nosotros podemos decir que es
un número racional
y entonces me vas a decir y cuáles son
los números que no son racionales ya
tenemos aquí a todos los números
naturales declarados enteros también
aquellos que tienen punto decimal finito
es decir que tarde o temprano acaba su
punto decimal en términos que tienen
punto decimal e infinito pero que se
repiten aquí es exactamente lo mismo el
punto decimal que se repite a todos
estos son números racionales entonces
cuáles son los que no son racionales y
bueno etiquetar a los números racionales
les llevó mucho tiempo a muchas personas
para saber después cuáles son los que no
son racionales así que qué te parece si
nos vemos esto un poco y vamos a
movernos justo por aquí y vamos a
fijarnos en estos números que tenemos
que la izquierda estos son unos números
irracionales y déjenme ponerlo aquí
números
y racionales
si o no
y seguramente tú vas a decir oye sal que
es un número racional bueno pues aquí
tenemos a los ejemplos más típicos de
números irracionales por ejemplo pin que
es la razón entre la circunferencia y el
diámetro del círculo es un número que
tenemos aquí el cual tiene un punto
decimal infinito tiene infinidad de
números decimales y nunca se repiten
y tiene un número infinito de decimales
y nunca se repiten que por cierto está
presente en el interés compuesto
continuo o en el análisis complejo son
dos de los lugares en donde podemos
encontrar a este valor a raíz de dos es
un número irracional tiene un número
decimal de infinito y nunca se repite si
el número áureo la proporción áurea la
razón dorada la divina proporción es un
número que tiene una cantidad de
decimales infinitos y nunca se repiten
así que estos números que aparecen mucho
en la naturaleza
muchos de estos números son irracionales
y bueno entonces seguramente me dirás ok
que padres están estos números
irracionales estos tipos de números
especiales pero sal hay muchos más
números racionales que números
irracionales como tus cuatro ejemplos
que tienes aquí pero lo importante
mencionar aquí es que tenemos sin este
tipo de números exóticos aquí pero
realmente no son bichos raros realmente
no son números raros o especiales o poco
comunes porque los padres de esto es que
siempre hay un número irracional entre
cualesquiera dos números racionales por
ejemplo si yo pongo aquí
dos no racionales un racional aquí y
racional uno un racional y un racional 2
siempre podemos encontrar entre ellos un
número irracional y bueno esto lo vamos
a probar con mucha más calma en uno de
los siguientes vídeos por ahora lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que tenemos
muchos pero muchos números irracionales
ya con esto te puedes dar una idea de
que tenemos una infinidad de números
irracionales esto nos da la profundidad
de la
junto en el que estamos y no sólo eso
las raíces de los números primos por
ejemplo aquí tengo la raíz de 2 es un
número racional pues la raíz de
cualquier número primo también es un
número irracional pero no sólo eso si
nosotros tomamos un número racional y lo
sumamos con un número irracional el
resultado va a ser un número irracional
y esto está increíble porque cada vez
empieza a verse más grande todo esto y
no solamente la suma si nosotros tomamos
un número racional y lo multiplicamos
por un 9 racional nos va a dar también
un número irracional así que imagínate
tenemos un montón un montón pero un
montón de números irracionales allá
afuera